let me ask you something so
so you make the bartender song was it to
a specific bartender girl
yeah did you ever go back to him like i
just made you
the sickest song of all time not at all
i think that song
at a [ __ ] hedonism really in jamaica
and everybody was ass naked uh
i had to borrow the xlr cable from a
[ __ ] dj
at the hedonism i i have the i have the
picture of
my setup it was just a laptop a [ __ ]
uh beach by dre
speaker and [ __ ] like that and it was uh
you know i only like the bartender
because
everything was free so yeah it was like
an all-inclusive thing so i was just
like [ __ ] drinking and drinking and
drinking drinking
and uh yeah a funny thing about that
song man
uh right after i made that song i saw
i went out and saw a bunch of uh
uh police tape around the the resort
and uh i didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on
and uh i just went to the bar again
and saw this guy oh white guy he was
just
like in his [ __ ] 70s
and uh
i i was just i offered him a drink i was
like man let's let's have some fun you
know just you know
not trolling or [ __ ] with people but
uh his name was bob
[ __ ] around with bob and he was like
uh
that police tape back there is uh
because my wife just died in the hotel
and um he said i was getting ready to
i was at the bar taking my last drink
and he was gonna kill himself he was
gonna kill himself
and he was like the the way you came up
here and
showed me love and just had fun with me
you and your friend
and i'd still talk to him to this day
that was like 10 days
let me buy you a drink
yeah i mean but it was like it was like
a
it was like i think i mean obviously it
was free but it was just like dude
like he was just looking down i was like
dude what are you doing get up get up
wow did some [ __ ] he was like i was here
taking my last drink and
i've been talking to i've been talking
to him ever since
oh my god wow yeah man that's beautiful
yeah
that was crazy and that that came from
barnes and that
the song bartender was made during that
and then all this [ __ ] happened at the
end yeah so you know
bob i love you brother i love you bob
i'll say
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm actually worried
about getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly
and it's all the stuff i wasn't allowed
to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats